Chris Rock's first stand-up special
since Will Smith smacked the crap out of
him at the Oscars finally aired and he
had a few things to say the comedian
made headlines when he announced that he
would be performing his brand new
special selective outrage live on
Netflix a first for the streaming giant
to celebrate the occasion Netflix tapped
a slew of comedians for a live pre and
post show some of the Heavy Hitters
brought in to comment on Rock special
included Snell Alum Leslie Jones Coming
to America star Arsenio Hall and The
Master of Disguise himself Dana Carvey
selective outrage marked Rock's first
special since 2018's tambourine which
was directed by fellow comedian Bo
Burnham after spending most of the
special railing against expensive yoga
pants and his own daughters Rock finally
addressed the elephant in the room or
the slap heard round the world last year
at the Academy Awards when Rock referred
to Jada Pinkett Smith who due to her
struggles with alopecia is bald as G.I
Jane Smith stormed the stage in one of
the ceremonies weirdest moments in its
history and wrapped Chris Rock right
across the face that slap immediately
became Infamous going down an Oscar
history and until now Rock hasn't really
talked about it well the Smiths have
publicly addressed the infamous slap
with the Fresh Prince star even
apologizing to rock the comedian largely
decided to keep quiet about the debacle
until he found the perfect platform and
thanks to a 20 million dollar check from
Netflix Rock got the chance to finally
address the now famous slap here's what
Chris Rock said about the Oscar slap
during his stand-up special rock waited
until the very end of his special to get
to the slap but when he got there he got
heated he sent two raucous Applause
y'all know what happened to me getting
smacked by sug Smith everybody knows
everybody [__] knows the comedian
continued by expressing how the slap
quote still hurts saying that he has
summertime ringing in his ears despite
getting slapped Rock insisted in the
specials final minutes that he doesn't
consider himself to be a victim saying
he took the hit Like A Champion Rock
repeated twice I took that hit like
Manny Pacquiao mother rock also
addressed that Smith is significantly
bigger than him physically noting that
Smith played Muhammad Ali in a movie
which to be fair is a decent Point
noting that Smith frequently does
shirtless scenes in his movies Rock had
this to say about his own physique if
I'm in a movie getting open heart
surgery I'm wearing a sweater the
comedian continued his rant by reminding
viewers that Smith daunts him physically
in animation too throwing a nod to his
appearances as Marty in the Madagascar
franchise Rock exclaimed I'm a zebra
he's a shark as for Smith's stint as a
shark rock is referring to the actor's
voice role in Shark Tale it should be
noted that in the DreamWorks flick Smith
plays a small fish who claims he can
kill sharks that clarification of course
doesn't make for a compelling joke
nevertheless Rock received a cathartic
series of Chuckles from the audience
finally he went after both Smith and
Pinkett Smith describing Smith as
practicing quote selective outrage Rock
said pointedly I didn't have any
entanglements a not so Sly reference to
Pinkett Smith's relationship with August
Alcina before saying that he tried to
call Smith after that train inspired
only for the I Am Legend actor to not
pick up the phone after calling out
Smith's Behavior Rock then turned to
Pinkett Smith the comedian recounted how
Pinkett Smith insisted that he quit his
gig as the host of the 2016 Oscars
because Will Smith wasn't nominated for
his role in concussion he said she said
he should quit because will didn't get
nominated for concussion so then I do
some jokes about her who gives him she
starts at I finish it Rock closed off
the special by saying he still quote
loves Will Smith expressing how he's
always admired to the Entertainer he
said I have rooted for Will Smith my
whole life the comedian then answered
why he remained cordial and calm after
the slap saying that he was raised by
his parents he concluded and you know
what my parents taught me don't fight in
front of white people then Rock dropped
the mic as expected Twitter naturally
lost their Collective Minds over the
special while it remains to be seen just
how popular Netflix's first ever live
event was Rock still clearly in his
feelings about the whole slap and he
certainly wasn't subtle you can check
out his special streaming on Netflix now
foreign